ja der krieg überschattet alles und er
führt uns vor allen dingen auch
dramatisch vor augen dass alles mit
allem zusammenhängt nach sieben jahren
also mal wieder ein g 7 treffen hier in
deutschland auf schloss elmau und zum
diesjährigen gipfel eingeladen hat
natürlich der deutsche bundeskanzler
also olaf scholz und zwar hier in emma
in oberbayern und so schön die idylle
hinter mir auch ist und die sie hier
auch sehen und die auch demonstriert und
gezeigt wird die situation ist natürlich
alles andere als schön darüber habe ich
gerade mit dem deutschen bundeskanzler
gesprochen und wir wollen uns das ganze
jetzt auch noch mal einordnen lassen und
zwar von unserem hauptstadtstudioleiter
aus berlin theo koll und von unserem
studioleiter aus washington elmar
theveßen schirm gutmann an euch beide
gute nord theo wie bewertest du denn
erstmal diesen ersten tag wir haben
gerade die ganzen tollen bilder gesehen
das ist eine riesige inszenierung aber
was ist denn eigentlich da an substanz
diese gipfel haben wir eine innere
dynamik und der erste tag ist gerne mal
der der symbolik da hat gestern sehr
viel der amerikanische präsident für den
bundeskanzler übernommen denn symbolik
und große gesten ist jetzt nicht das
haben wir herausragende zeichen von olaf
scholz und man sah ja gestern das beiden
das übernommen hat er hat den arm um den
kanzler gelegt er hat die hand auf
seinen arm noch mal gelegt und gesagt
mach's gut du bist einer unserer besten
und schnellsten verbündeten also das war
das klare signal des gestrigen tages an
der substanz wird sowieso gearbeitet die
abschluss erklärung en das sind der
mehrere wahrscheinlich sind ja auch in
arbeit und da wird heute und morgen noch
vieles passieren
diese bilder haben sich natürlich auch
interessiert du bist in washington auch
hinter den kulissen unterwegs und du
hörst natürlich auch die kritik an
deutschland deswegen war das besonders
wichtig dass jetzt der us-präsident dem
bundeskanzler gelobt hat absolut aber er
will was von ihm und das ist ganz
besonders etwas was die amerikaner
ärgert in den letzten wochen gab es ja
signale ein stück weit aus deutschland
auch aus frankreich man hat sich ja
geäußert dass man schauen müsste wie
putin das gesicht wahrt dass man ihnen
nicht zu sehr
verletzen könnte und die amerikaner
sehen das anders sie sagen wir müssen
härte zeigen müssen langen atem zeigen
das heißt klar machen dass man die
ukraine langfristig unterstützt sowohl
die nächsten monaten als auch darüber
hinaus und nicht irgendwie schon
überlegen wie kann man den die ausfahrt
bauen für wladimir putin man will dass
die ukraine geländegewinne wieder
erzielt also gebiet zurückerobert damit
putin von sich aus in eine position
kommt aus der sagt jetzt muss ich
verhandelt ich habe den bundeskanzler
gerade auch nochmal gefragt weil um 10
uhr wird der ukrainische präsident sie
lenski zugeschaltet und man kann davon
ausgehen dass er nach weiteren waffen
fragt und bittet haben wir mal rein was
der deutsche bundeskanzler dazu gerade
gesagt hat
der klima club handelt davon dass man
zusammenarbeiten soll zwischen den
staaten die bereits sind sehr schnell
bis zur mitte dieses jahrhunderts co2
neutral zu werden es gibt
unterschiedliche wege die die staaten
einschlagen wollen aber das ziel muss
immer das gleiche sein deutschland ist
da ja sehr ehrgeizig wir wollen es schon
2045 schaffen geht das weiß der falsche
ton den zur ukraine hören wir uns dann
gleich nochmal anderen nehmen wir gerade
das thema auf klima club das ist auch
eine idee des deutschen bundeskanzlers
da will er die g7 vereinigen elmar das
ist aber ein problem denn es soll eine
einheitliche so heißt es co2 bepreisung
geben und da sagen die usa kanada japan
machen wenn ich also ist er damit schon
gescheitert das kann man sagen zumindest
in diesem punkt weil es geht einfach
nicht in den usa das ist sache der
einzelnen bundesstaaten das kann ich in
washington entschieden werden aber es
ist eines wichtig glaube ich zu
verstehen in der tat am ende das ziel
ist das entscheidende wie man den weg
dahin baut kann unterschiedlich sein in
usa ein beispiel hat die
princeton-universität zehn verschiedene
wege aufgelistet wie man
klimaneutralität 2050 in den usa
erreichen kann also am ende kommt es
darauf an dass man es angeht dass man
taten vorantreibt geld investiert das
ist in den usa an den gange im gange und
der kanzler sagt zumindest das sei auch
in deutschland und jetzt haben wir auch
den o-ton vorliegen zum thema
waffenlieferung immer das gesagt dass
man es angeht und er ist es angegangen
jedenfalls aus seiner perspektive
deutschland liefert sehr viele waffen
das wird auch überall anerkannt wie sie
ja selber berichtet haben eben und das
ist ein gutes zeichen dieses gipfels
deutschland hat weitreichende
entscheidungen getroffen der das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das
wir auf den weg gebracht haben die
höheren ausgaben für verteidigung die
massive unterstützung der ukraine wird
überall als ein wichtiger beitrag
deutschlands bewertet und ist es im
übrigen auch das ist gut manchmal so
zusammen zu kommen weil das ja den blick
etwas weitet und dann auch klar macht
dass tatsächlich gerade deutschland eine
zentrale rolle spielt und sie auch
weiter spielen wird
sagt also der bundeskanzler hier vor
knapp einer halben stunde die führung er
hat ja mal gesagt wer sie bestellt der
bekommt sie auch jetzt wurde aber kritik
laut auch übrigens emma aus den usa
hinter den kulissen hieß es da muss
deutschland eigentlich mehr machen der
spd chef lars klingbeil sprach plötzlich
von deutschland müsse jetzt auch mal
mehr führung übernehmen versucht er das
jetzt auch so ein bisschen medial zu
streuen na ja man sieht ganz deutlich
dass der spd vorsitzende im grunde einen
schritt weitergegangen ist er hatte in
dieser grundsatzrede anfang der woche ja
gesagt deutschland muss nach 80 jahren
der zurückhaltung
führungsmacht sein das ist ein großer
schritt weiter als das was der kanzler
bisher gegangen ist und ist interessant
lars klingbeil ist ja er auch ein
pragmatiker er auf der rechten seite der
spd und man sieht daran dass er
offensichtlich nicht nur eine diskussion
in der spd anstoßen will wie weit gehen
wir eigentlich in dieser neuen
sicherheitspolitik die ja für die spd
wirklich auch ein tabubruch ist und wir
werden in der nächsten zeit erleben nach
der schockstarre dieses kriegs und die
spd muss ja dann auch jedes jahr die
versprochenen zwei prozent für die
rüstung einhalten dass wir sicherlich
eine diskussion in der spd bekommen und
da wird es interessant sein wie die
kräfteverhältnisse sind immer
kräfteverhältnis ist natürlich ein
spannendes thema auch noch mal du hast
gerade schon das verhältnis zwischen
deutschland und den usa angesprochen es
wahnsinnig interessant waren gestern die
bilder vielleicht haben sie auch schon
gesehen also beiden also den deutschen
bundeskanzler irgendwie am arm
tätschelte er siegte mit den worten
nicht zuletzt ein verdienst dass der
westen seit dem einmarsch in die ukraine
zusammen gehalten hat was steckt da noch
dahinter also ich glaube die beiden
erkennt dass deutschland bereit ist
seine theorie zu akzeptieren wir sind in
einer großen auseinandersetzung zwischen
den demokratien auf der einen seite und
dem autoritarismus auf der anderen seite
und er braucht deutschland um da eine
führungsrolle zu spielen denn es geht
nicht allein um russland es geht auch um
china die usa sehen in china die große
bedrohung der zukunft und das bedeutete
am ende dieses wandel durch handel hat
sich erledigt aus amerikanischer sicht
und man braucht auch deutschland um
china gegenüber sehr klar zu machen wir
handeln mit euch nur wenn eben es auch
veränderungen gibt und wenn china nicht
weiter daran arbeitet die weltordnung
wie wir sie nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
gesehen haben zu zerstören und deshalb
auch diese 600 milliarden für die
infrastruktur das ist ja ein ganz klares
signal oder hast du china stichwort
seitenstraße absolut das ist aber auch
die strategie die der kanzler hier ganz
klar verfolgt mit der einladung an diese
fünf großen nationen denn man muss ja
sehen die g7 waren mal bei gründung die
großen führenden nationen das ist ja
heute gar nicht mehr so klar der fall
man hat indien nach china die nicht
dabei sind und was jetzt versucht wird
ist in dieser
sich ankündigen auseinandersetzung mit
china und den usa und klammer auf wir
sind ja von china viel abhängiger als
wäre es von russland sind im moment ist
das große thema unsere energie
abhängigkeit aber wenn wir mal schaut
dass vw 40 prozent seines umsatzes
gewinns in china macht das große teile
der deutschen industrie abhängig sind
von china dann ist das eigentlich das
große neue thema und das suchen jetzt
nach allianzen und verbündeten und
beeinflussung der fünf gäste das ist das
wichtige und das sind vor allen dingen
drei große länder die heute auch im
fokus stehen werden das sind indien
indonesien und südafrika die will man
sozusagen auf die seite der demokratie
ziehen das ist gar nicht so einfach denn
die haben weder den krieg russlands
krieg wirklich verurteilt sie haben sich
enthalten und sie finden die westlichen
sanktionen auch nicht so richtig gut
auch darüber habe ich mit dem
bundeskanzler gesprochen und wir müssen
hier auch solidarität zeigen denn der
russische angriff hat ja konsequenzen
für die ganze welt viele länder fürchten
eine hungerkrise viele länder fürchten
massiv steigende energiepreise wie wir
sie ja auch spüren wegen den neu
entstehenden knappheiten und dass sie
möglicherweise nicht die nötige energie
für ihre länder besorgen können und da
muss man solidarisch zusammenstehen
diese solidarität wollen wir auch zeigen
ich hatte ihnen eigentlich gefragt wie
konkret er diese länder überzeugen will
mit geld aber er hat dann eben mit
solidarität geantwortet davon kann man
sich aber auch nichts kaufen oder immer
jahres wird schon mit geld unterfüttert
wir haben ja gestern gesehen ein
infrastrukturpaket 600 milliarden dollar
allein 200 milliarden aus den usa die
idee war vor einem jahr schon im urlaub
beschlossen worden jetzt tut man butter
bei die fische und das sind im grunde um
riesige infrastrukturprojekte
kommunikationsnetzwerke energie
netzwerke und diese länder brauchen das
und sie haben bisher das in erster linie
von china bekommen china hat durch die
seitenstraßen initiative dadurch auch
macht und einfluss gewonnen aber das
ergebnis war dass die verschuldung
dieser länder in die höhe geschnellt
deswegen der kreditbedingungen gegenüber
china und das eben auch viele projekte
in korruption versunken sind und das
will man anders machen es ein angebot an
diese lande zum beispiel senegal als
vorsitzender der afrikanischen union
ganz entscheidend wenn die hier weggehen
von diesem gipfel und den eindruck haben
die meinen das ernst die machen das
tatsächlich endlich mal taten nach den
ganzen worten dann könnte es tatsächlich
dazu kommen dass diese geschlossenheit
ein bisschen erweitert wird die meinen
das ernst das soll ja auch das signal
richtung putin seien also nicht nur geh
und entschlossenheit sondern wirklich
auch tatkräftiges handeln gestern wurden
aber vor allen dingen auch so an der
seite ein paar witze über wladimir putin
gemacht der das wissen sie vielleicht
auch sicher gerne mal mit
koerfer zeigte
jacke an oder die jacke aus wir müssen
härter sein als putin sagte er da noch
und der kanadische die metro
durchmustern vor man solle sich die
puschen 2009 einfach die bei damals beim
reiten mit nacktem oberkörper zeigen und
dann gab es wiederum von johnson witz
mit wir müssen unsere bauchmuskeln
zeigen was ist davon zu halten
das ist ein typischer johnson ich
befürchte er wäre auch der einzige der
wirklich damit nacktem oberkörper sich
hinsetzen würde was wir alle nicht so
richtig wollten der ja auch in die
fluten gesprungen ist um war ja auch
immer zu demonstrieren vielen herzlichen
dank an euch beide m at wissen
studioleiter aus washington wir sprechen
morgen auch noch mal weiter denn der
nato gipfel steht der direkt nach diesem
gipfel an theo koll
hauptstadtstudioleiter aus berlin vielen
dank für diese einordnung der
einschätzung und jetzt erstmal wieder
zurück ins studio nach berlin